hi i'm emily perry i'm an application
scientist with agilent
and today we're going to talk about pfas
analysis in water we're going to talk
about both targeted
and untargeted techniques
first i want to define what exactly i
mean by pfas
pfass is an acronym that stands for
pearl per and poly fluorinated alkyl
substances
a perfluorinated substance means that
every hydrogen in an alkyl chain has
been replaced with a fluorine so that's
a very high degree of fluorination and
the example i'm showing on this slide is
phos
a poly fluorinated substance is one that
has
a couple hydrogens left in the alkyl
chain an example here is
six two fluorotellum sulfonic acid
which is commonly referred to as six two
fds
now p-fast is a really broad category
there are greater than four thousand
p-fos
compounds used today in commerce
on the right side of the screen you see
kind of like subdivisions of that
within this broad class and by far the
ones that are most studied
are the perfluorocarboxylic acids
and they're shown at the top and you
could how much
more they're studied than the others
you'll note if you look at the right
column there's a
list of the number of peer-reviewed
articles
and then the top compounds have
thousands more
than some of the uh lesser studied ones
that are lower down in this chart
so why are there so many of these
compounds used well they're
they're unique structure makes provides
them
valuable properties useful in
manufacturing and in industry
for example the high degree of
fluorination helps with thermal and
chemical stability
so they've been often used in grease
proof food packaging
stain and stain repellents they also
have zwitterionic properties that make
them really good surfactants
and also they have surface tension
lowering properties which makes them
really good fire fighting foams
that last point is important because
that property has made them very useful
for military bases and airports
both facilities need to run fire
training exercises
and respond to actual fires the aqueous
film-forming foam or a-triple-f
is a highly efficient type of fire
suppressant agent
that contains fluorochemicals at high
concentrations
the runoff from these exercises can
create large inputs of fluorochemicals
to the environment
so they these chemicals provide really
valuable properties to industry
so why are people concerned about them
well the longer chain compounds have
been shown to have negative health
effects
and have been found in drinking water so
that has really created a public
concern about their presence
this slide just represents a quick
internet search i did last week
and there are many recent articles on it
you'll note that two of them
are for military bases
and that's really is because of some of
the the fire
training exercises and the use of a
triple f
so this public concern has created um
you know a need for drinking water
regulations and this is not a problem
unique to the united states
you can see there's worldwide
regulations and the it really
depends on the country and what are the
particular concerns of that country
you'll note that the us they have uh we
have a
federal health advisory from the epa of
70 nanograms per liter total pfos and
pfoa
to take a closer look at the united
states you can see that the levels vary
among u.s states as well
much depends on the industry in the
state and what has been found
so for example if you look at north
carolina it has gen x there and you'll
note gen x isn't listed for any of the
other states
um a couple years ago gen x which is a
replacement compound to pfoa
pfoa is one of the long chain compounds
that was initially phased out years ago
and gen x is its successor
so gen x was found in the cape fair
river and
has been of particular concern in north
carolina
and you'll see the different states have
different compounds of concern
and generally the levels are a lot lower
than the federal guideline of 70
nanograms per liter
so this really highlights the need for
sensitive robust methods to measure pfas
in water
this is a list of the current standard
and consensus methods available
you'll note that the first one was epa
537 and it was released in 2008
and then there really wasn't much done
until around 2015
when we get another astm method and then
recently there's been
quite a few methods released the epa
most notably released
epa 533 at the end of last year and
that's a new drinking water method
that kind of expands the analyte list
that's in 537 and i'm going to be
talking
specifically more about that method
later
if you want if you're looking at water
other than drinking water there's epa
8327 which is still in draft form
but it's very similar to astm 77 7979
which they're basically the same except
for they have a different analyte list
there is also an iso method that was
released last year
when you're thinking of doing pfas
analysis in water
there's method considerations based on
your end goals
so if you have water you could do sample
preparation which could be
offline sp solid phase extraction or
online spe
or you can do a direct aqueous injection
also you would need to consider when
doing pfas analysis your lc
configuration
many components of the lc actually
impart
background into your analysis so you
want to make sure you
take the necessary steps to mitigate
that
also are your goals targeted or
non-targeted if you're doing a targeted
analysis just looking at for a specific
list of compounds
say for regulatory uh reasons
then a triple quad is a really great
option and then within that there are
different
levels of sensitivity required
if you're doing non-targeted and looking
more for you know new and emerging pfas
compounds
then high resolution mass spec is more
the choice that you would want to make
because that
mass accuracy allows you to do formula
generation
and kind of structure elucidation
experiments
so specifically i'm going to first start
by talking about
the background removal steps that you
should take for your lc
on the right side of the screen you see
an lc stack with different colored boxes
so each of those boxes is kind of
highlighting a part where
you can have background introduced into
your analysis
some of the potential contamination
sources they could be solvents
if you filter your solvents if the
filtration
apparatus can actually introduce
background also many times
in a typical lc setup the tubing that
goes from your mobile phases down to
your binary pump
is fluoropolymer so that obviously can
leech out and cause background in your
analysis
so we have for a background elimination
kit
if you purchase an lc from us we
automatic and we know you're going to do
pfas analysis this kit is
automatically included and it's
installed when the service engineer
sets up your lc essentially it replaces
all the fluoropolymer tubing with
peak tubing it also bypasses your
degasser in the
in the pump because the digester is a
known source
of fluoropolymer background or
fluorochemical background
um also your lc your autosampler can
have uh
potential sources of background all the
tubing would be replaced with peak
tubing
but in addition to that you need to be
concerned about the type of vials and
caps you use
for that you are storing your samples in
so most lc vial caps are teflon lined
and in this case
that can actually be very bad so you
want to be make careful choices when
you're
deciding on those things
this slide shows the great
uh how efficient the kit is at removal
it shows the
pfos and pf hxs
before modification then after we do all
these modifications to your stack
they're completely gone
but in addition to doing uh the
background removal i always recommend a
delay column just because sometimes
there are
things that you can't control for
example there could be pfas
in your lc solvent so in that case you
want to have
a delay column and that column is placed
after the mixer but before the auto
sampler
and what it does is delay the pfos that
from the background
and separate it from the pfos that's
coming from your sample
so you would end up with two peaks like
this with the first peak
being the actual pfos peak and then the
second
peak being the delayed peak and if
you're doing targeted analysis this is
really simple you can just set your mrm
window so you don't even see the delay
peak
so it's just basically a problem free
way of
making sure you have a nice clean
background one thing to be cons
to always consider though is the delay
column does not account for any
contamination coming from the auto
sampler
it only helps with the pump and the
solvents and that's because the auto
sampler is after
the delay column so for b
so for um doing non-targeted analysis i
would
definitely recommend implementing the
whole kit
just because you don't want to be
identifying things in your from your
samples that are actually just coming
from your background
and here so once you have your lc set up
you still have to do
you know your sample prep and consider
the vials that i mentioned
i just want to give a little shout out
many people don't know that agilent
actually purchased a standards company
so we now
sell environmental reference materials
and that
includes some pfas standards that are
shown here on the slide
we also sell the the vials and the caps
that
are you know floral polymer free
so you won't impart any backgrounds
there
we also sell some of the solid phase
extraction cartridges that are used in
the methods that i'm going to be talking
about
we've covered the background removal
the sample prep and now let's briefly
talk about your analytical choices
for analysis if you're doing targeted
analysis
versus non-targeted that's kind of how
this slide is divided up
targeted analysis you would probably
want to use a triple quad
and we have three triple quads in our
portfolio
and they are arranged here as the
from the more routine and to the
ultimate sensitivity end
the ultivo is um our routine
quantification
um and then it's a stackable lcms so it
has a greatly reduced
footprint then you have the 6470 and
then the 64.95 for ultimate sensitivity
depending on what kind of sample prep
you're doing that would help you decide
which one of these would best suit your
needs
i'm happy to announce uh for the first
time at asms
2020 that the 6470 now has
vac shield for no vent capillary
cleaning
previously the ultivo and the 6495 had
that but i'm very excited to announce
that it's now
also available on the 647d
if you are doing non-targeted analysis
maybe a q-top would or a high-res
instrument
would be more what you need and we have
several q-tops in our portfolio
listed here i'm probably specifically
only going to talk about the
which is the newest addition to that
family
and it also has gate valve for no vent
capillary cleaning
now let's jump into some methods and
results for targeted water analysis
epa 533 is the newest really released
epa method for drinking water
and it has some differences from its
predecessor
epa 537.1 um
first it covers more analytes you have
25 analytes versus 18.
they by switching the cartridge from the
sdvb
in the 537.1 to the wax cartridge in the
533
they were able to capture some of the
smaller analytes and you can see that in
the chart
on the right side of the screen the top
pfba and pfpea
are shorter chain compounds so they
weren't actually in 537.1 but they are
in 533
by adding those compounds they did
delete some of the longer chains that
were in 537
are not in 533 you'll note those on the
on the right side of the blue chart
midway down
um another difference between the two
methods is 533
is isotope dilution while 537 just used
internal standards
so you will be purchasing a lot more
isotopically labeled compounds
to run 533 so it is a little bit of a
more expensive method
they also change the final extract from
96 methanol to 80 methanol
and that's really to try and improve the
chromatography of some of the shorter
chain compounds
it's it's doing a full pfas analyte list
is always compromising
between the long chains and the short
chains since they seem to like different
chromographic and like solution
conditions
another change for epa 533 is they
required now they require two ions for
reporting
while in 537.1 that was not required
this method has a requires a 250 times
concentration factor
so it's perfect for routine instruments
like the ultivo and the 6470
i'm going to give a little bit of
introduction into our old tivo
it is the first stackable triple quad so
it just
you know resides at the bottom of the lc
stack which greatly reduces the
footprint
in your lab and in order to make it
that's much smaller than some of our
benchtop models the whole
interior of it had to be re-engineered
and the whole goal while they did this
was to reduce the footprint but maintain
the robust
sensitive performance of our benchtop
models
and i've used the ultivo specifically
for 537 and i can say that it performs
very well for that
besides the five uh the ultivo the 6470b
would also work very well to do 533
um and as i mentioned earlier the newest
release of it will now have vac shield
which can reduce your
downtime for when you need to clean the
front end from 6 hours to 30 minutes
this is a really robust instrument that
is very popular
and the the new version is pretty much
the same except for the vac shield
so if you can expect to have the same
routine
rugged performance that the other one
gave this one
works great for routine but it also can
give you a little extra boost if you
want to do
research applications on it here i'm
showing a comparison
of the ultivo and the 6470 for epa 533
second lab validation data we had
two labs that use our instruments
participate as secondary lab
validation and they all calculated the
lowest concentration minimum reporting
level
using both the ultivo and the 6470.
this lcmrl value considers both accuracy
and precision in analytical measurement
so it's a very robust value
and
you can see that both the ultivo and the
6470 for the most part performed very
well
in comparison with the epa single lab
lcmrl
you'll note that most of the values here
are below
or at to or around two nanograms per
liter
and that's kind of important i've had
many conversations with
uh customers and you know no one's
really certain where these regulations
are going to end up
but two nanograms per liter seems to be
kind of
the consensus goal that i've heard so
you want to really be able to measure
down pretty low
so 533 specifically for drinking water
this one the epa 8327 is for
non-potable water which would include
surface water groundwater and wastewater
it's currently pending released by the
epa
and it's as written the
range that it looks at is 10 to 400
nanograms per liter
what's great about this method which
many people really enjoy is that it's a
dilute and shoot method so you would
just take
five ml of your of your sample water
dilute it with five mils of methanol
filter it add a little acid and then
you're ready to inject so
that's a very simple sample prep
procedure that
that many people appreciate so we did
participate
in the epa as a second lab validation
for this method for the epa
and for that we use the 6470
and we we got really good results that
i'm going to show you
well within the method range
but as i mentioned no one really knows
where these regulations are going to
end up so many people want to go lower
so i'll show you some results
that i developed on the 6495 using this
method
for the second lab validation on the
6470 we got really good accuracy and
precision at the low level of 10
nanograms per liter
we also got a really good surrogate
recovery in the unknown water samples
now this list that i'm showing here is
slightly expanded
from the epa list we did add in
five more compounds that are not
included in the
the method list we did that just because
these are up and coming compounds some
of them are in 533
and there many people are interested in
monitoring for them for example the
compounds for
that are included in the formulation
f53b
are included in this list all these
results are
available in great deotel in the
application notes cited on the bottom
of the screen and i'd encourage you to
take a look at that if you're interested
and the question is is those some people
want to go less than 10 nanograms per
liter and if you want to do that
then you might want to take a look at
the 64.95
this is our instrument that we sell for
ultimate sensitivity it has
an ion funnel and at this point we're on
the third generation
it also has the vax shield technology
again for the the vent free
cleaning so this one it has a hexa bore
capillary in the front end as opposed to
both the altivo and the 6470 that have
the a single bore so the hexavore
capture lets more ions in
and then the ion funnels help remove the
extra ions on the neutrals which
help maintain the robust performance
uh but the hexaport capital while
allowing more ions in it it keeps the
diameter small of
this on six small holes so it doesn't
allow too much dirt in which
allow for both of those things combined
allow you to really maintain robust
performance
with the 6495 while still getting that
really ultimate sensitivity and i'm
going to show you some data that
supports that
for the for re the method detection
levels that i calculated on the 6495
using epa 8327 we were able to get most
compounds in that list
down to two or under nanograms per liter
detection levels there were some that
were a little bit higher
only one that was six or less
however and in for comparison it's not
shown on this slide but the 6470
all of the levels were at 10 nanograms
per liter
and they all except for two compounds
and those were actually at 20 nanograms
per liter
so the 64.95 is really able to give you
that extra boost of sensitivity if you
require it
i mentioned the robustness that the 64
95 is able to maintain and that's kind
of what this slide is trying to
illustrate
now if you take a look at each of one of
these little charts
they represent the each point on the
chart represents that
a calibration point and in between each
of those dots we injected
10 wastewater samples and then we took
another calibration reading
this is really just to verify that your
calibration
area counts remain stable even though
you're introducing a lot of matrix into
the instrument
and they're not normalized by an
internal standard there
i normalized them by the average area of
that particular compound
and you can see the rsds actually next
in the parentheses next to the compound
name i'm only showing six examples here
and they're all around six percent rsd
rsd and that six percent is calculated
over
100 over 100 sample injections and a 36
hour batch
now some some of the longer chains did
have slightly higher
rsds they were all well below the method
standard which is
30 percent but the longer chains might
have
had a little bit higher than six but i
don't think that has anything to do with
the 64.95
it has more to do with them sitting in
that vial for a long time
you know during the course of these
repeated injections and this really long
work list
so it likely just indicates that the
vials needed to be vortexed
because they've been sitting so long and
a lot of times the longer chains have a
tendency to absorb to the
vial walls
so 8327 is a dilute and shoot method but
if you're willing to
do some spe you can get really great
sensitivity
on the 6495 because you can add in that
concentration factor
this this slide is representing
work done by a collaborator in australia
and he has done an application note for
us he's
given this lcgc seminar and it's also a
peer-reviewed publication so there's
many ways you can interact with this
content
what's really interesting about this
work is he includes a really large
analyte list
up to 52 compounds and so far none of
the methods that i've talked about
have nearly that many compounds included
in them
so you can look at the the source
parameters and the transitions and that
could be really useful if
some of these special ones are the ones
that you're interested in measuring
so i would encourage you to take a look
at that if you're interested
so far we've talked about offline fb and
direct injection or dilute and shoot but
if your experimental goals and allow it
another great option
is online sbe and we're able to achieve
this
using just two extra components in your
lc stack
it would be the 1290 infiniti flex cube
and then also an extra quaternary pump
so with those two components you can do
some really complicated plumbing
and include two spe cartridges
wax cartridges in this case and the
extra pump allows you to do like while
one column
is being loaded the other column is
being alluded and sent
to the analytical column for analysis
so with this alternating method you're
able to greatly reduce
the amount of time that it would take to
do an sbe extraction
for any of you who've done offline fbe
you can imagine that it takes a great
deal longer than it would take
to just do these two load and elude
steps that you build into your
analytical method
with the cycle of two columns it ends up
being around 32 minutes which
anyone who's done offline sbe knows that
it takes a great deal longer than 32
minutes
so with this setup we're able to get
really good results
here we're showing good pressure
reproducibility on both the binary and
the quaternary pumps
we get excellent retention time
stability
good peak shape and we maintain
separation of the linear and branched
isomers
some robustness data for the online sbe
so this chart shows both pfos and pifoa
with their
isotopically labeled analogs the green
boxes show the calibrators
and then s3 and s4 are repeated
injections of these alternating samples
and you can see that even you know for a
very long
alter many alternating runs that they
maintain really good
area counts with the one exception um is
that there does to
appear to be a saturated peak in sample
s3
and that really kind of highlights an uh
you know an additional benefit
of the online system is if you have some
kind of saturation like that
instead of having to actually dilute the
sample you can just inject less
all the injection volumes that for these
samples that you see
is 475 microliters
and that's also another benefit is if
you're doing an offline system you have
to extract 250 milliliters
here you only need 475 microliters
and that is essentially that whole mass
is essentially injected onto your
analytical
columns you can get some really great
sensitivity
and here i'm showing the linearity now
all the results that i've presented so
far for this off
online spe system are on the 6470
and with this injection volume we get
really great
sensitivity down to 0.1 nanogram per
liter for pfoa
and one nanogram per liter for pfos so
far today i've only really been talking
about the targeted workflow
and as the title indicated i'm going to
talk a little bit now about untargeted
screening
which you would typically do with a
high-res mass spec instrument
and the one i'll highlight for this
application is the 6546
it's the most recent addition to our
qtof portfolio
and it's a lot like the 6545 except for
it has a lot more muscle
it allows the acquisition of data in
high resolution and extended dynamic
range
it also has a higher resolution than any
of our previous trip or qtof models
at 108 at 118 mass over charge that
provides over 30 000 in resolution
it also includes some new acquisition
features such as
quadrupole resolved all ions and it does
have the capillary gate valve
as i discussed for the triple quads
and best of all it has the same
sensitivity isotope fidelity and
robustness that was
made the 6545 so popular
when using high reso high resolution
mass spec really allows you to do
screening for a large number of
compounds quickly
you can start by building a personal
compound database library
this can include as little as just an
accurate mass or as much as collision
spectra and retention
time we do have libraries available for
purchase while one for
pfast is not yet available we do have a
water contaminated database that does
include some pfast compounds
quickly screening your data set can
allow you to tentatively
identify emerging pfas once you do
further experiments
to fully just elucidate the structure
that spectra and retention time data can
be added to the pcdl
another benefit of high-res mass spec
data
is that when you run your sample you
collect a full spectral scan for that
whole sample
which allows you to re-review historical
samples once you identify new compounds
and that is really not possible with
triple quad data
this particular slide illustrates a pdf
pcdl scanning a wastewater sample and
the identification of 62fts throughout
the water treatment process
to complement the suspect screening
there is a true non-targeted analysis
this involves identifying new pfas
compounds
and to do this you really need structure
elucidation tools such as targeted msms
and software which will allow you to
create fragments and then software tools
that help you identify those fragments
and rebuild a structure that they come
from
and one of those software trolls that we
offer is the molecular structure
correlator
once you fully identify these compounds
you can add them to your pcdl
and your rescan your historical data
during this presentation i have
discussed kind of two approaches for
characterizing pfas in the environment
and they are complementary we have the
complete workflow available from
analyzing known knowns to identifying
unknown and emerging pfas compounds i
hope the information presented has been
useful and would be happy to answer any
questions via email
and of course i'd like to acknowledge
all my collaborators and
colleagues i didn't generate much of the
data i presented here myself so of
course i would like to give credit
where credit is due so thanks thanks to
all of them
and of course thank you to you for your
attention